今日はダンマパダの読む日です
あの十九番目の偈です
［外国語］で あの意味はまあそれほど難しくはない偈なんですけど
バフンピっていうのはあの分析するとバフンとアピ API
のアピなんですね まあバフンっていうのはたくさんということでね
大量ということで アピはちょっと大量であってもとかという風なような意味なんですね
サヒタンっていうのは
この元の言葉はサンヒタンですけど
この偈のためにあの仕様の節を守るためにサヒタンという風にしているんです
で サンヒタンというのはこのテキストですね
いわゆるいろんな教えをまとめて集めた
編集して作ってる まあテキストのことをサンヒタと言うんです
で そういうことで あの
サン サヒタン サヒタンがテキストというか
まあ例えばある教えがあるとしますね
その教えに関わる まあ全ての教えをまとめて編集して
もうたくさん本やらテキストやら作るでしょうし
そういうのはサンヒタと言うんですね
まあ昔からインドでね
本は書かなかったんですけど
本は作ってあったんです
書けないだけで ちゃんと作るんです
例えばあのヴェーダ正典というね
四つあります すごい量が多いんです
その場合でもリグヴェーダサンヒタ
ヤジュルヴェーダサンヒタ
サーマンヴェーダサンヒタ
アタルワンヴェーダサンヒタという四つの名前でサンヒタという言葉を使っているんですね
リグヴェーダといっても結構分厚い
まあバカでかい編集なんですよ
で だいたいテキストのあの偈だけじゃなくて
あの読み方やら注やらね
解釈やら そういういろいろ入ってますからね
で そのヴェーダ四つに対して書かれた上から書かれた本というのは
それからブラァフマナサンヒタというというテキストシリーズがありまして
これがもしかするともう本棚一つ軽々と一筋はいくんですよ
全部まとめちゃうと かなり量なんですね
だからサンヒタという一言葉でまとめるんです
だからたくさんあるっていうことなんですね
一言葉にはサンヒタ値はない
そういう まあ本などをね
テキストなどをね バフンアピ
いくらたくさんであってもということでね
バハサマノという言葉の意味は喋っているという
語っているというね だからたくさんテキストをね
いくらたくさんテキストをというか
もう教えというかね 語ってもという意味になるんですね
一行目の意味は 大量に教えを語っても
語っていても バハスというのは語るということで
でもそれだけの意味じゃないんですね
ただ喋るっていう意味ではなくて
ヴァーサティっていうことは
インドの文化で言えば
よく勉強して 研究して
プロになって 教えたりするということなんです
ですから ただ喋ってるっていう意味ではないんですよ
かなり深く厳密に研究して
勉強して 理解して その上
次の世代にも教えていると
うん 講義といったら講義だけになって
語るというふうの方がね
講義よりは正しいとは言いますけどね
で 語るといえば講義だけでもないんだから
何か語ってるっていうことは
その人はそれをスタディしているということにもなるしね
まあヴァーサティということは
勉強する 研究するという意味でも使います
ですから いくらたくさん教えをね
だからサヒタンというのは
その場合は教えというふうに訳しなくちゃいけない
サヒタンはテキストとして訳したっても
ちょっと悪いんですね
だから いくらたくさん教えを語ってもということになるんですね
そこでこの場合はサヒタン
テキストを編集している教えのまとめといえば
この偈では何を意味するかというと
お釈迦様の教えを見せているんです
ヴェーダではないんです
お釈迦様が語った教え
お釈迦様の教え 仏教をいくらたくさん自分が語っていてもという意味になるんです
だから原題 お釈迦様が亡くなってから編集されたんですけど
だから今我々知っている
もう何でしたっけ 経 お経とやらアビダンマやら戒律やら三蔵経ありますね
で 三蔵経の中でも経典の場合はまた五つに分けてもう整理していますけど
でもテキスト形式にするということは
このヨーロッパの学者の方々はね
それは随分後で 弟子たちが勝手に作ったもので
ブッダの教えではありませんと言いますけど
それはまあ西洋の思考であって
インド人はちょっと違ったんですからね
でも西洋で認めないんだから認めるわけにはいきません
インドではもう遠い昔
この紀元三千年前からでも
やっぱりテキストは作るんですよ
で これどこを見ても本見つからないんだから
もう西洋人にはもうないんだと
そこではもう紙に書くのはもうエジプトやらね
中国とか その両方で始めた文章文化だから
もうあまりインドではね
紙に書くという文化はなかったんですね
でも先生は何か教え 自分が分かったことがあったら
それは一つ一つ偈に 偈を作って作って作って
ちゃんとチャプター作って分けて
それで自分が作った偈に自分で注を入れて
こういう意味でこういうことですよと
それで自動的に頭の中で完璧なテキストができてるんです
それは弟子たちに教えて暗記させちゃう
弟子たちはそれを勉強して
さらにそれに注釈やらつけたりして
また別なテキストになったりもする
そういう風に学問的な文化っていうのは発展していったんですけど
紙一枚もならないんですよ
それでも だから勉強すると言ったっても
大体もう三十歳になるまでもう勉強するんですよ
昔バラモン人は かなり時間かかる
で だから一部の人々にしかできなくなったんですね
勉強っていうのは だから数学もありますし
数学でも全然紙には書きません
どんな難しい数学でも
もう全部頭でやるんです
で 一応あの まあ文字やらね
まあ印やらね シンボルやら使っていたみたいですが
その場合はこのちょっと一時的に何かあって
そこでちょっと書いて
こういうこういうことでこうこうなるんだぞと
それ消してしまいます
それで終わり 頭で覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですね
で 自分の国でも昔このインド文化でこの聞いたことがあるんですけど
この紙はないということで砂のボード作るんですよ
だそうです 見たことはないんですけど
ボードがあって それで砂があるんです
それで書くんです 砂の上で書いたっても
すぐ消せますからね そうするともうたくさんたくさんいくらでも勉強できる
書いては消す 書いては消す
書いては消すと ですから
この勉強して終わったら
自分の手には一つもノートがないんです
ノートはないんだけども
絶対忘れられない ものすごい知識人にはなっているんです
だからお釈迦様の教えもお釈迦様が亡くなってからもう編集したんだそうと言ったっても
これはそんなに当てにならない話なんです
教えはみんなお坊さんたちは全部それなりに編集して覚えていたんです
それは議会に出して賛成してもらっただけなんです
いろんな地方のお坊さんたちがもうもうお釈迦様が亡くなってからできる作業で
これがブッダの教えですということは認定してもらわないと
まあそういう認定式ですね
この結集というふうなことで
昔やったのお釈迦様が亡くなって 三ヶ月間経って
それで各地方のお坊さんたちが五百人ぐらいね
阿羅漢たちで集めて 全部これでこれでこれでこれとかね
全部もうとっくにまとめてあったもんだからね
では これはブッダの純粋な教えであることはどういたしますかと
ただみんなそれはもう賛成ですと
それで仏教の世界では全会一致で満場一致で賛成しなくちゃ有効じゃないんですよ
まあ変な世界だからね
で 普通の知識人の世界ではね
もうもう一票でも多い方が勝ちますけど
で 五百人千人集めたところで
五百一人賛成だったら
たとえ四百九十九人反対であろうとも
まあそれはOKになっちゃうし
それは知識人考えてる民主主義のやり方で
仏教ではそういう風に考えてないんです
千人集めたら千人で賛成しなくちゃいけないんです
一人でも反対するともう無効なんです
だからといってやたらに拒否権を使うこともできません
だから反対する人にとってはものすごい責任があるんです
並ならぬ責任があるんです
千人集めたところで一人が反対すると
だから九百九十九人に対して並ならぬ責任が成り立つんです
彼が九百九十九人も納得させなくちゃいけないんです
で それで納得いったら
また満場一致でそれはもう否決されます
そういうふうなやり方でやってますから
民主主義とも言えないんですね
仏教は だからこの結集というお釈迦様が亡くなって 三ヶ月間経ったところで
そこで一応テキストをお坊さんたちの議会で阿羅漢たちの議会で可決させて
それから二 三回も五 六回もまあ聖正説会ですけどね
歴史的にいろいろ問題になってくると
また同じ結集をやるんですよ
インドで三回 それからスリランカで一回
とにかくこのミャンマーでもう一九五六
七 八年でやった結集は六番目になってるんです
だから五番目どこかわからないんです
スリランカで二回やったんでしょうかね
覚えていない それで結集したんだから
六番目ミャンマーで六番目の最後の結集をしましたからといって新しい経典書いたんです
全然書いてないんです
昔の経典そのまんまで
またもう一度新しく読み上げて
これはブッダの教えであることは
みんなで千人一致で賛成しますと
やるのはこの今までいろんなところでやったテキストやら全部まとめて
このテキストの文字間違いやら言葉間違いやったら
ではどんな言葉にしましょうかとかね
ミャンマーの結集にはもう今までやったいろんな各国の経典は全部そちらに揃ってもらうんです
そこでいろんなタイからお坊さんたちがいて
スリランカからも行って
行く人々は一番最高のレベルの学者のお坊さんたちが行くんです
行って話し合って この言葉はこれで
この言葉はこれでとか
決めるんです ですから
パーリテキストのタイバージョンがありまして
ミャンマーバージョンがありまして
スリランカバージョンがあります
それに加えて ローマ字のイギリス人のバージョンもあります
今世界で使ってるのはそれなんですけど
それがイギリス人が作ったんだからって完璧ってわけじゃないので
いろいろ間違いはもう見るいろんなところありますけど
それはちょっとずつ文字間違いやら発音の間違いやらそんなもんでね
だからこの結集を見て
西洋人がその時書いたもんだよというのはね
それは西洋的な思考で
マインド的な我々にとってはもう別にそんな話は気にしないし
まあ勘違いってことも私たちは分かってますけどね
言ってはいかんから言わないだけで
だからこのサヒタンという言葉っていうのは
テキストという意味で
もうダンマパダにも入ってるしね
お釈迦様の教えでもやっぱりいろんなところで教えると
それはその場でその場でいくらかテキスト形式にその場でなるんです
暗記するためには一応まずテキスト形式にする
お話した全部 雑談やら世間話やら全部使うわけにはいきません
それでこういう話でしたと
こういうわけで こういう出来事で
必要なエピソードだけ入れて
出来事だけ入れてテキスト形式にする
それはテキストの文化で
だから紙に書かない本は存在するはずがないと思っちゃうと
まあ話は成り立たないだけなんです
昔 インドではもう紙に書くということさえも考えてなかったんです
この紙に書き始めたのは
このまとまったテキストではないんです
紙はなくて葉っぱでしたから
葉っぱに書くんですね
葉っぱの方が紙よりもすごい頑丈で
まあ長持ちはしますよ
もう何千年もね だから守っておけば
紙 葉っぱそのものにも調整しますから
それからはもう何百年では持ちます
しかし カビ生えたり虫に食べられたりしちゃうと
もうもう だからいつでも触ったり手入れをしなくちゃいけない
常に触ったり使ったりするんだったらもう結構持ちます
それで紙に書く 書いたのはこのまとまりなものじゃないんです
一番最初に書いたのはこのブラックマジックなんです
ヴェーダの ヒンドゥー教の
すごいたくさんあります
このアタルワンヴェーダっていうヴェーダがあります
そちら半分はブラックマジック大量にあります
そういうのはこのやたらに知ったら困ると
ということで葉っぱに書いておく
でもそれの使い方やら勉強の仕方やら
また先生から教えてもらわないとできない
で そこら辺はもう紙にあったんですけど
でもコピーは作らないんですよ
それでも だからもう考古学的にあっちこっち掘ってみたっても見つかりっこないんですね
で コピーはもうまあ 生徒が自分のコピー一つ作るかもしれませんし
それは一つのコピーだけで
自分の一生それを守っていて
あるいはその同じテキストを弟子にあげるか
弟子が何人かいるんだったら
まあ弟子たちは自分のテキスト作るかと
それはもうブラックマジックの世界で始めたもんなんですね
それからこの他のまとめの教えでも
まあほんのちょっと一行二行とかね
一言葉二言葉とか ちょっと書いておくっていうことはあります
その今の経典発掘して見つかるのはそういうものなんです
ブラックマジックマジックと黒魔術のことですか
悪い魔術のことですか
このいろいろ発掘したりすると
仏像 仏塔をね 発掘したりすると
経典の一部が見つかったりしますね
で その場合は そのその人々は大事に思っていたものだけ
ちょっと書いてそちらに置いて入れておく
だからそれも読むためじゃないんです
だからそれで今発掘してるのはそういうもので
そういうものから調べて完全な経典なんか作るかなんて
それは無理な話でね 完全なもの見つかりっこない
誰も書きませんだからそういう風に
だから唯一完全に残ってるのはパーリ経典だけなんです
また他のものもあったんですけど
みんな性格だらしないんだからね
守るということは命かけてやらなくちゃいけないし
スリランカの昔の和婚たちは
これもう命かけてもうすごいきつく守ったんです
もう何が何になっても
もう教えだけは守ると
ということで すごいきつ
苦労したんですね だからそれはパーリ経典だけ完全な形で残りましたし
他の宗派の人々も同じブッダの経典を持っていましたけど
もう完成したものっていうのはないんですね
中国でも阿含経は 4つはあるんですけど
完成していない バラバラですよ
編集もそれほど立派じゃないんですね
しかし 学者はそちらへんはすごい正しいっていうふうな立場で
そこを基にしてパーリ経典を勉強批判というか
学問的に批判したりするし
合わないとは思いますけど
やり方はやり方でやってるんです
で 阿含経なんかあったっても
また戒律はなかったし
それで結局は戒律のは欠けてるんだぞと思って
それは調べにインドに来たってスリランカに来て
スリランカにあった戒律テキストを持っていって
そこであの入れたんです
そうするとさらにもう調子が狂っちゃうんですよ
で テーラワーダ仏教の戒律ですから
宗派仏教は自分で戒律書き換えたりしましたしね
で まあそこら辺でだからすごいごちゃごちゃ何がなんだかわからない漢文経典になっているんです
同じものいくつかあったりとか
あるいはあるべきものがなくなったりとかね
あるあるべき場所から別な場所に引っ越ししてあったりとかね
こういうことは学者にとってはすごいありがたいことで
もう何百年でも研究できると
永遠に だから誰一つも一人もこのまとめな結論は出さないんですね
いつでも曖昧で終わっちゃうんです
それは話は別に関係ない話で
こちらで言っているのは
サヒタンというのは経典という意味なんですけど
で で 経典 経典であろうともブッダの教えという意味になります
それでブッダの教え ブッダの経典をバフンピ
ものすごいたくさんバーマ様の専門家になって語る
語っている人になってもね
講義できる人になっていても
次の行 二行 ネタッカロホーティナローパマット
ナっていうのは否定形でしないという意味で
タッカロ タッカロっていうのはそのように行うという
いわゆる言ってる通りに行うという意味なんです
タッカロホーティ 行うことはナ
ありません いわゆる教えに言われている通りに行う
実践することはないと
パマットーナロー ナローパマット
パマットーっていうのは怠っている
怠けている ナロー 人が
その通りに実践することはありません
まあこれで終わりです
それぐらいもう意味は簡単単純です
だからこの怠けてる怠ってる人がそのいくらたくさん経典を勉強して講義して語っていても
その言ってる通りには実践はしない
という意味です いわゆる大量に経典を勉強して
ものすごく勉強して すごいプロになって
自分が語り続けている
しかし 自分でこの内容で言ってるような実践の方は
それはもうかなり怠って
忙しいと 自分が先生だからとかね
いう態度で もう実践してみようということはしない
それで その人のことを三行目で
行目で説明します 行目は喩え
ゴウポーガガオーガナヤンパレーサン
ゴウポーっていうのは牛飼いのこと
ガオー 牛たち ガナヤンっていうのは
稼ぐ パレーサンというのは他人の
だから牛飼いが他人の牛を稼いでいるような感じで
この牛飼いには牛がいない
仕事はまあ牛の面倒見ること
それでたくさん牛を持ってる人の牛の面倒を見る
すごい真剣に まあガナヤンというのは稼げるって意味って言いましたけど
本当はもう朝連れて行って餌を食べさせて水を飲ませて
まあ夜になってくるとちゃんと稼いで牛小屋ね
入れておく 一頭でもなくなっちゃうと
この人は責任持たなくちゃいかんのだから
もともと牛一頭持ってない人だから
一頭なくなったらもうどうしてももう
勉強できんでしょうに
だからすごい真剣 自分の牛だったらね
一匹死んじゃっても まあ虎に食べられたってもね 「
あーかわいそうに一匹亡くなったんだよ」というぐらいで終わりますけど
自分で一匹一頭の牛でも飼えるお金はない
しかし 食べる方法もない
それで人の牛をね まあ五十頭とかやら四十頭やら
なんとかもう貸してもらって
自分が面倒見てあげる
その場合はまあ子牛でもね
ちょっと怪我したりなんて大変なことになります
だからすごい真剣に守らないと
その意味なんでガネヤンっていうことはね
ネバーガワーサマンニャッスホーティ
これで あのー たくさん意味を補って解釈しなくちゃいけない偈なんです
しかし 補うんだからって意味は間違わない
これは昔からもうちゃんと意味ははっきりしています
で 補うところはこういうところ
だから他人の貧しいね
人が 貧しい牛飼いが他人の牛をね
面倒見るとどれほど真剣にやるかと
それはできれば感じてほしい
牛一頭ちょっと病気になっただけでも
この人責任持たなくちゃいけない
病気になってでも森にで死んでしまったら
これ大変なことになる
だからきつい仕事なんですね
牛と一緒にいるのは楽だなとかね
牛があっちこっち草食べてる間で
どこかに木の下でゴロ寝していられて
いいんじゃないかなとか思っても
責任は重大なんです まあインドだから虎もいるわ
まあ狼はいないんですけど
ライオンもいましたしね
だから守らないとね そこでそこまで必死になって苦労して命かけて牛たちを守っている
でも結局は彼には何を得られますか？と
これは一日の給料もらって帰るんです
大したことじゃないんですね
ただの労働ですから 一日食べられるぐらい何かもらって 「
あ 今日ご苦労さん はい
これ持って帰れ」と それで終わるんです
もらうものはそんなほんのちょっとなんですね
でも自分がどれほど責任でビクビクして仕事をしているかというところ
並大抵のものじゃないんです
だから夜全部数えて牛小屋に入れたところで給料もらうんだからね
一頭でも減っていたら
もう給料をもらうんじゃなくて
命があげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
自分の命まで それなのに一日ですごい大金もらえますか？という
全くそうじゃないんです
その日の生活できる分ぐらいの
もうほんのちょっとの
労働は未だにインドですごい安いんだから
この一日の給料で生活している人々っていうのは本当にきついんですよ
一日二日仕事なくなっちゃうと
もう終わり もう何も食べるものなくなっちゃうんです
着るものやらその他の贅沢じゃなくて
食べるものさえもなくなっちゃうんです
買えなくなっちゃう それぐらいほんのわずかな給料なんですよ
だから この他人の牛を見る人の悲しい状態はそんなもんで
そこでお釈迦様は四行目に行きます
それで仏教を厳密に勉強して
ものすごくプロになって語り続けていても
その人の場合も同じだと
ネバーガワサマンニャッスホーティ
彼がサマンニャッス サマンニャッスっていうのはサマンニャ
サマナっていうことで
出家したこと 出家の結果
出家して得るべき得るはずのご褒美はもらわないんだと
バーガワっていうのはそちらの
あの 自分のシェア 何と言いますか
分け前でしたっけ  果報ですか
え？ 果報ですか  何ですか
果報じゃない え？ 報酬
シェア え？分け前ですね
出家して自分得るべきご褒美というか
その分け前はもらえません
また牛に戻ると なんで人が牛を飼うかというと
牛たちからいっぱい財産がいただくんですよ
牛にも餌と草だけ 水と水をあげてそこら辺で藪で食べさせればいいんだからね
別に餌をどこから買ってあげなくてもよろしいし
牛は自分たちで餌を探して食べるんだから
まあお話が言いでしたからね
でも牛を持ってる人はその牛たちですごい財産が得られます
毎日毎日 特にインドではこの一番宝物
財産だとほやかしていたのは
この 牛からもらうこのパンチャゴウラサというんで
五つのゴミっていうんですか
五つの ごちそうというかね
美味しいもの 牛乳やらヨーグルトやらバター
チーズとかね それから油ですね
で その五つは牛の牛乳から取るんですね
で だから牛がいるということが
その五つのごちそうに恵まれる
それで牛乳から取る油っていうのは一番高価
それはもう救国のごちそうだそうですね
いつでも経典でも インド本
インドの他のテキストでも
もう最高のごちそうという意味言う場合は
もうこの油のことを言うんですね
牛乳から取り出す油 ですから
まあそれはそんなにたくさん作れないでしょう
たくさん作れないし だからちょっとしか食べられないし
すごい金持ちだったらいくらでも食べられます
だからこの牛を買った人がこうやってもう財産に恵まれます
そこでオスの牛たちはもう仕事をする
だから今から言えば 何か運送会社をやってやっているような感じなんですね
もうはっきり言うと運送会社なんですね
オスたちはもう運送会社で物を運んであげる
牛舎はありますから そちらでいっぱいにもっす入れて
牛たちはそれをあっちこっちあっちこっち持っていくんだからね
軽々と 牛を持ってる人には運送会社も経営できる
何も苦労することはない
それでメスたちが子供を産んで
もう毎日毎日限りなく牛乳のプロダクションやってますから
殺して食べるということはなかったんですからね
確かに殺しちゃったんですけど
これはバラモン人が神のために
神の生贄のために殺したんであって
一般人が牛を殺しちゃうと大損だと
それでそんな殺すはなかったんですけどね
バラモン教の人々はもう生贄
んだから まあ牛十頭必要よ
二十頭必要ですよって言って
もう殺しちゃいますね
殺したものを食べなくちゃいけない
それで食べたりしたんですけど
ではなくて もう自分飼ってる牛を殺しちゃうと
それで全部なくなるんだよってことでは殺しはしません
年取っても殺しはしない
年取った雌牛たちでも雄牛たちでも
やっぱり群れを守っているんだから
そういうボロボロの牛たちいたら
もう小さな子牛たちが守られるし
それでも虎が飛んできても若者は逃げちゃうし
まあ捕まってもそういう歩けない
走れない ボロボロになってる牛でしょうし
そういうことでよくバッファーになってきてね
ガードになってくれるんですね
遊び回ってる子牛たちでも
やっぱりあっち行ってこっち行って
もうもうなんか心配だなと思ったら
もう母を見つからなかったら
そういう年取ってる牛たちはあっちこっちあまり行かないんだからね
そこら辺に来て集まる
まあそういうことで 年取っても牛は殺さなかったんですね
死ぬまで守る それがヒンドゥー教でも残酷に動物殺すことを応援していましたしね
バラモン教ではね まあ牛の
とにかく牛があること財産です
それでパーリ語でナッティゴーサミタンダナという言葉もあります
ゴーサミタン 牛に等しい財産はありませんと
それは当時の価値観なんです
だから金持ちというのは場合は
たくさんの牛を持ってる人やというんですよ
金持ちというのは金持ってるっていう意味でしょ
インドではそうじゃなくて牛持ちというんですね
金ではないんです 金は貨幣としてはね
そんなに物々交換のものでしたから
金には金銀宝石の価値はありましたけどね
あくまでもね アクセサリーですから役に立たないんでしょう
だからそんなに高いだけであって
価値は入れてない 一部の人々が使うものであって
人間には生きるためにはどうしても必要というものではまるっきりない
ですから 財産でといえば
まあ牛だぞと 牛 土地とかね
そういうものにしているんです
それでこの 牛飼いの人が自分では牛を持ってないんだから
人の牛の面倒を見ているんだから
金持ちで牛持ちですけど
金持ちじゃないんですね
毎日毎日牛と一緒にいるんですね
命かけて守ってるんですが
貧乏なんです 本当はそれぐらい牛があるならば
すごい大金持ちですごい贅沢できるはずなんです
でもこれができない 牛二頭
四頭いたってももう豊かなんです
当時では もう借金する必要も何もない
お金ちょっと必要だったら
オスの牛をね まあ仕事に出せばいいんだから
それでも運送業に出しちゃえば
これ一日 五日 十日間出したってもいいし
もう仕事する人は餌あげなくちゃあかんだからね
餌と水を それで一週間
一ヶ月間終わったところでお金もらうだけ
はい 牛と金ちょうだいと
だから牛二頭 四頭あればもう豊かで生活できます
でもこの人はどうですかと
ほんのちょっとの給料もらうだけですから
そのような感じで出家して
経典をむちゃくちゃ勉強してプロになってもなってみんなに教えている
語り続けている しかし
何も得られませんと ただ
パートタイマーですね
この大きな会社で ちょっとしたパートタイマーで会社の株主にはならないんだと
パートタイマーがほんのちょっとパートタイマーと正社員であっても
給料の差がすごいでしょうに
彼があの出家したことで
あの何にも相続権利はなくなるんだよと
サーマニャといえば まあ一応まあ相続権利なんですよ
だからブッダのところに出家したならば
ブッダが得た解脱 涅槃という
あの究極な幸福を得られる
権利がね 相続できる権利が成り立ってるんですね
仏弟子たちだからね しかし
それはもう実践するならばの話で
実践しないならば仏弟子にはならんと
仏 その場合 仏弟子とは言わない
仏子ですね ブッダの子ですね
ブッダの子にはならないんだと
はい 意味はまあそれだけのことで
それで番目に行きます
アッパンピチェサヒタンバスマノ
ダンメスダンマッセワホーティアヌダンマチャーリーラーガンチェドサンチェパハヤモハンサマッパジャノスウィムッタチットアヌパーディアノイダワウランワサバーガワサーマニャッサホーティ
アッ
パンピチェサヒタンバスマノダンマッセホーティアヌダンマチャーリーラーガンチェドサンチェパハヤモハンサマッパジャナンスウィムットサマッパジャノスウィムッ
タチットアヌパーディアノイダワウランワサバーガワサーマニャッサホーティ
で意味説明します アッパンピ
たとえわずかでも ほんの少々でも
サヒタン ブッダの教えをバーサマーナ
まあ語っている いわゆる語り
その場合は勉強しているところですね
まあ自分に語れる勉強できることは
ブッダの教えのほんのちょっとだけ
ほんの少々なんです ですから
たとえほんの少々でもブッダの教えを理解して
ダンマッセバーホーティアヌダンマチャーリー
この一番目のダンマっていうのは
そのブッダのその教え
自分が知ってるほんの少々の教えに対してアヌダンマチャーリー
その通りに従うこと そこでその通りに行うこと
このダンマという言葉
二行目二つありますけど
意味は同じじゃないんです
1番目のダンマはブッダの教え
自分が勉強したあの少々の教え
アヌダンマチャーリーというのは教えではなくて
あるものを実践する この規定によって言われる通りに
その法則に沿って実行することをアヌダンマチャーリーと言うんです
だから その場合のダンマは仏法という意味ではなくて
何でもいいで教えですね
何でも法則やら決まりやら何でもいいんです
マニュアルということなんですね
だからどんなマニュアルでもいいんです
そのマニュアル通りにやると
だからアヌダンマチャーリーは日本訳するならばね
やっぱりこの原理に従って実行するっていう意味なんですね
原理ですかね プリンシプルというものがありますから
原理やり方というものがありますから
そのやり方に従って行ってみる
実行してみる その意味をアヌダンマチャーリーっているということで
ですから アヌダンマチャーリーという言葉を使う場合は
ダンマはそれが何なのかを先に言ってもらわないと困るんです
ただ 彼が原理を守っていると何の原理ですかとわからないでしょうに
規則を守っているんだと言ったっても
どんな規則ですかね あの人は規則をちゃんと守って生きているんだぞと
それでは意味わからない
どんな規則ですかと あの人は学校の規則はちゃんと守っているぞと言わなくちゃいけない
あの人は会社の規則はちゃんと守っているんだぞと
あの人は家の決まりはちゃんと守っているんだぞとかね
ですから この決まり守っている規則を守っているということをアヌダンマチャーリー
ガイドラインに従ってやっているっていう
そういうことで そのガイドラインは何ですかと言わないと意味がないでしょうに
この場合はブッダの教え
ブッダの教えもこの人はたくさん知っているわけじゃないんです
アッパンアピですから
ほんのちょっとでもいいやと
ほんの少々でもブッダの教えを理解して
その教えのガイドラインに従って実践してみる
その教えに従って実践してみる
それで彼がどうなるかというらーがんちゃ
どーさんちゃ ぱーや もーはん
らーがんというのはラーガ欲ですね
ドーサンというのは怒りですね
それから次の言葉飛んでモーハン
モーハンというのは無知ですね
ラーガドーサモーハ ローガドーサモーハとも言いますし
ラーガドーサモーハとも言いますね
ラーガ欲 ドーサ怒り モーハ無知
ぱーや なくして消して
消してしまって ということで
取り除いてということで
それは 3行目の意味 それで 4行目に行きます
サンマッパジャーナ サンマッパジャーナっていうのは
これはそのままの言葉で
これはサティ 皆さまが実践している
サティのことなんですね
常に気づいている状態にサンマッパジャーナと呼ぶんです
昨日の話でも同じことを言いました
常に秒単位で自分に気づいていないと悟れないんです
気づいてない状態は怠ける状態と言うんです
今の瞬間で何が何やってるんでしょうかということなのに
常に気づいてないならば
もう怠けている サンマッパジャーナっていうのはそうやってもうずっと認識っていうのはずっと起きてるんだから
瞬間瞬間でそれで気づいている
今こういう風なこと 今こういうこと
今こういうこと 今こういうことということで
だからこれは気づきのことで
サティのことで ヴィパッサナーのことなんです
私は瞑想するときは実況しなさいと言っているのは
それは手段のことで 実況しなくても常に今の瞬間に気づいていればそれが本物で
でもそれであまりにも難しくて
何か道具を使わないと我々にはできないんですね
だからもう実況中継はこの常に気づくことが掴む道具なんです
だからこの言葉でもって実況しないでできる方法っていうのはね
これはもうないでしょう
おそらく できると威張ってる人々はいますけど
あまりにも頑固でわがままで
私には面倒くさいという言葉で実況する
私はじーっと感じているだけで十分できるぞと
それで私はそれではなくて
本人の性格をちゃっと見るんですね
この人はなかなか頑固者で
もうめげる人ではありませんと
それで はいはい それで結構ですと言うんです
それで私はもうその人はもうカットしているんです
それからは指導も何も心配もなし
また もうすみませんでしたと言ってくれない限りは
もう終わり で もう育てないんです
だから見ているんだから
これできないんですよ
だから調子に乗るんじゃないんです
自分の心の管理できればね
それはもう悟ってるんだから
心は管理できるものじゃなくて
勝手に怒ったり泣いたりわめたり落ち込んだり
心は勝手に妄想でやってるんだからね
笑いたいんだけど 聞いていたって笑えない時もあるでしょうし
例えばストーリーでも言ってあげて
この場合は泣きますよと
では泣いてくださいと言ったら泣きますかね
このところでみんな笑いますよと
ですから あなたは笑ってくださいと言って
そうやってドラマとか成り立ちますかね
ドラマを見ていたっても
一人が泣いているかもしれません
一人が全然面白くない
面白くないとボケっとしているかもしれませんでしょ
だから それは人間に管理できるところじゃないんです
だって すごい面白い話をしても
相手が必ず笑ってくれるとは分からないんですね
だから心っていうのはね
自分でもわからないものなんです
では 自分に聞いてみたら
自分が何を聞いたら笑いますか？何を聞いたら泣きますかと知ってますかね
だからこの 調子に乗っちゃうと
もう終わりですね それはもう育てない人のドゥッバチャというパーリ語で専門用語言葉ありますからね
ドゥッバチャだったらもう失格ですね
だから慈悲の瞑想でもスワチョという言葉ははっきり入れてるんですね
スワチャドゥッバチャ
それはもう反対語で スワチョワっていうのは
スワチャっていうのは
このスワチョ 育ちやすい
人の話を聞くっていう意味なんですね
いわゆるアドバイスを聞く
頑固でわがままで 私は別のやり方でやりたいんだよと
そんなことは言わない
知ってる人が教えるんだ
教えているんだから まあ素直にそれを実践してみる
その通りに 文字通りに
そうすると その文字通りに結果が得られる
だから素直ということですね
スワチョっていうのは
それの反対語はドゥッバチャ
まあ頑固ということで
ドゥッバチャだったらもう育てられませんと
それで比丘たちにお釈迦様
比丘たちが破滅になる
堕落する原因を語るときはドゥッバチョドゥッバチャッサカラニーエナダンメーナサマンナーガと
もし比丘たちがドゥッバチャで
頑固で 頑固になる思考しか持ってないんだったら
もうそれで仏教は終わりと
破滅やと 丸っきり自分で管理できないんですね
全くも だから私ではないか
私のものではないかと言えるものは一つもないんですね
勝手ですよ 体も勝手でしょ
それで勝手で我々には何を作ってくれるんですかね
勝手でも良かったならばいいでしょ
全然そうじゃないんですね
体勝手に変化して もう体を病弱にするんですね
ガンなんかみんな嫌がりますけど
だったら作らなきゃいいでしょうに
そんな嫌だったらなんでガンになるんですかね
バカじゃないんですか
高血圧嫌だったらならなかったらいいでしょうに
そんなこと自分勝手でできるんですかね
一つも自分勝手にできないんですよ
それからものすごい怖いといえばね
脳出血とかなんとかでしょ
脳梗塞って言うんですか
心臓発作だったら瞬間的に痛いだけで死んじゃいますから
それはありがたいことに
脳梗塞はもう地獄ですよ
死なないし しかし それっきりでもう体動かない
それ嫌でしょうに だったらそんなことしなきゃいいでしょ
脳梗塞起こさなきゃいいでしょうに
がんにならなきゃいいでしょうに
高血圧に糖尿病にならなきゃったらいいでしょうに
そうなりますかね 自分で勝手に考えても
体は体の勝手なんです
それで体の勝手で体を動いて何を作るかというと
全部もう危険なことばっかし
体は勝手に機能して 何をやっても何か問題
何をやっても何か問題
それは体の法則 では心はどうですか？だったら心は俺のものですかと
思ってはいるだけで 全くも心は心の勝手で
悲観的で怠けで もう一日二十四時間も寝たままで
何にも気づかない 鋭さはまるっきりない
と言っても それは本当は嫌でしょ
だったら鋭くなれば 毎日泣いたり悲観的になったりして不幸にいるんじゃなくて
いきなり思考を明るく変えてみればどうですかね
そううまくいかんでしょうに
希望があっても 妄想で精神的に病気になって医者のところに行くでしょうに
だったら妄想しなきゃいいでしょ
それだけで解決するでしょうに
でもそうはいかないんですよ
いくら言っても妄想する人は妄想してしまっちゃう
それでまた病気になってしまう
それでまた凶暴になって人を殴ったり殺したりもする
そういう精神的にいかれてる人
あんたね それを妄想してはいけませんよと
あんた妄想してるでしょと
妄想しなきゃあんたすごい普通の人間になるぞと言っても
その人でそれできないんだからね
でもその人に聞いたって
もう心は誰のものですか？それは俺のものだよと堂々と言うんです
だったら自分で管理すればいいでしょうに
でもそういう風には管理できない
何一つも 私たちはいつ泣くか
いつ怒るか いつ欲張るか
いつ落ち込むか 分かったもんじゃないんです
そのその瞬間でどうなるかわからない
それぐらい心っていうのは全くもわがままで
暴走状態で 体もわがままで暴走状態で
この暴走状態で変化している二つを集めて命というんですよ
それはお釈迦様の話はそうなっているんです
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
この瞬間瞬間のこの暴走しているこの体の変化
心の変化 瞬間瞬間チェックしてみてくださいと
瞬間怠らないで すぐ直りますと
それですぐ全ての問題解決します
それしか道がない 暴走状態で
この体と心のね それは瞬間瞬間チェックすると
こうだからこうなった
こうだからこうなったということがよく分かってくるんです
こうだから怒った こうだから欲張ったと
この花にこういう風に花を見たんだから
欲が出てきたんだと この花はこういう風に見たんだから
怒りが出てきたんだと
この出来事はこういう風に見たんだから
自分が落ち込んでしまったと
それでものすごい素晴らしい智慧が現れてくるんです
どんな智慧が現れてくるんでしょうかね
普通の人っていうのは限りない無知で無明にいるんですね
落ち込んで落ち込んでしょうがないんだと
だって周りの人々はこういうことを私に言うんだから
私の家庭では兄弟はみんなすごい勉強できて
人好し 人間関係が良くて
それで自分がそういう環境に育てられたんだから
もうなかなか能力がなくて
ずっと引っ込みというかね
悲観的になってしまったと
だからみんなもうだからしょうがない
それ私の性格だとかね
いろいろ言い訳を 宗教家だったら
まあそれはそれなりに神様が何か計画あるでしょうと
だからそのまま受け止めてくださいとかね
それも一つの言い訳なんですね
納得いかないことに言い訳作る
それではもうあなたは神様に文句言う必要はないよ
神様は何か計画があって
あなたの子供は早く死んだかもしれません
あんた決めることではありませんとか言うよ
それで納得いったような雰囲気になる
とにかく納得いかないことに
いつでも神様 仏様が現れてくるんですね
そういうふうに世の中っていうのは
人間いつでもこういう何でも自分で管理しているんだというね
錯覚がある それ破れる時は神に管理しているという
本当はすべて自分が支配しているんだぞと言っていたんですけど
よくよく見るとそうじゃないんです
待望の子供が生まれたんだけど
病弱でもう 1歳  2歳で死んでしまったと
そうすると自分で管理しているんだという気持ちが破れちゃいます
自分ではもう必死で子供を長生きさせてやるぞと頑張ったんだから
それで では神様に管理している
俺じゃないと平気で言う
一つもそういうのは知識人の知恵のある人の考え方じゃないんです
初めからもうおかしいんです
思考は科学的じゃないんです
だから 1 秒  1 秒ではなくて
瞬間瞬間 体の暴走状態
心の暴走している状態
ずっとチェックする まあ体は暴走と言っても
体がすごくゆっくりのんびり変化するんだから
一応分かりやすい 体は物理的な法則だから分かりやすい
お腹が空いてくる どんどん体が弱くなっていく
分かりやすい 体が弱くなってくると気分も悪くなっていく
それでご飯を食べる 気分が良くなる
しかし 大量に品物を体に入れちゃったんだから
体がなんかだるくて動かなくなっている
それで気分悪くなった
気分が治りましたけど
その代わりにもうだらしないというか
眠くて眠気が出てきて
それを 1つ1つ体のことをチェックすると明確に見えてくる
心はもっと難しいんですけど
そうやって瞬間瞬間物事を見ると
こうだからこうなった
こういうことでこうなった
こういうことでこうなったと
100%の確率性があって発見できるんです
それが科学的な事実なんです
それで何を発見するかというと
体の法則を分かってくるんです
心の法則も分かってくるんですよ
それで次にひらめくんです
やっぱり私のものではなかったと
1つ それで私のものっていうのは
私っていうのは単なる言葉
空 空です ただの音 私ということはただの音になっちゃって中身はないと
ただ 体と心に対して 私
私と対して言っただけなんです
それも分からなかったんだから
体のことも分からなかったんだから
心のこと分からなかったんだから私と仮に言っただけ
あの 例えば我々も何かすごい分からないこと来て
これは奇跡だ 魔法だとか言うでしょうね
ごく一般的に こんなのは本当に奇跡ですね
奇跡的に助かりましたとか
そういう風に一般人が奇跡的に助かりましたとか言う場合も
本当はなんであの言葉を使いますかというと分からないんですね
なんでそうなったかと分からないんだから言うことで
これ科学者もよく言うんですね
これがもう神しか知りませんよ
いつでも平気で言うんです
何かほんの何か発見して
これがなんでそうなるかと
それはもう神のみ知ってるんだよと
だから科学者は神を信じてるんだからね
本気で言ってる可能性もあるし
まあ信じてない人でも平気でそんなこと言っちゃうしね
私はすっごく腹が立つんだ
そういう知識人がね 無責任な言葉を使うと
一般人が使ってもいいんですね
自分ではもう何も訳の分からないこと
これはもう神様のことだとかね
もう平気で言ったってそれは構いませんだけど
それは自分では分からないって意味ですからね
ですから 分からないんだから
我々は奇跡だ 神だと言う
それで私だというのもそれなんです
体と心の法則は分からないんだから
私だと言ってるんです
私の心だと 私の心で言ったら心を
心は全然私のこと聞かないでしょうに
まるっきり私のことを聞かないものに
なんで私の心と言うんですかね
だったらアメリカのブッシュ大統領は私のおじいさんだと言ってください
で 言えますよ 平気で胸を張って
それがそう言ったって
いかにバカにされるかとみんなに
自分のおじいさんだったら
これ私のおじいさんだと言ったら自分言うことを聞くでしょうに
私のということは自分言うことを聞く
例えば 私たちには誰かの協力が必要になりました
偉い人で 我々コネもなくてアプローチもできない
それで あの人だったらこれできるのにと言っているところで
一人が あ その人 私のおじいさんですけどと言った途端
我々はどう言うんですかね
いきなり飛び上がって
ああそうですか ではこれお願いできませんかと
それその人大丈夫大丈夫
まあ言ってあげますと
そしたら自分のおじいさんだから
電話一本おじいさんこれこれこういうことちょっとやってちょうだいというだけでしょうに
で 私たちにはアプローチもできなかった人なんですけど
その人は何のことなくそれやってくれる
私のという場合はそれなんですよ
だからその人はその人のおじいさんなんです
しかし ブッシュ大統領が私のおじいさんだと言っても
何もできんでしょうに
会うことどころか電話もできんでしょう
では電話かけてみてください
どう踏ん張っても繋がりませんよ
だから我々の心もそういうことで
どんな風に言っても心は自分言う通りにはやってくれないのに
私の心だ 体はどういう風に頑張っても自分の希望通りにやってくれないのに
私の体ということほど愚かな考え方はあるんですかと
だからその法則を分かったところで
ああ こういう風に動くもんだと
ああ 実は私のものではなかったと
わかることに智慧と言うんですね
それが第一ステージの悟りなんですね
それで神に 神に祈りすれば
あなたは永遠に命を得られますって言ったら
ニコッと笑うだけ その人は
明らかに間違っている
もう愚か者たちの話だと
もうとっくに分かっているんだから
その人は だから煩悩が 3つなくなりますよと
で その修行はこのサッマッパジャーノという一言葉で言ってる
あの気づくこと 常に気づく
瞬間瞬間自分に気づく
瞬間瞬間自分に気づくことはものすごい難しいんだから
言葉で実況してみる 言葉で実況することは完璧というわけじゃないんです
だって あげますと言ったっても
たくさんことをやってるんだからね
あげます 運びますと言っても
いろんなたくさんのことを瞬間でやってるんです
なかなか言葉でそれは確認できん
言葉っていうのはあまりにももう荒っぽくて大雑把で
厳密にこの瞬間には合わないんです
だからそれほど  いい道具っていうわけじゃないんです
まあとりあえずしょうがない
今あまり見当たりませんだけど
若者が何かスケートみたいなものに乗って
このハンドルもあって
それで足で蹴って蹴ってあっちこっち行ったりしたでしょ
あれ何と言いますか キックボード
キックボード キックボードってやつ
で あれで結構早く行けますよ
これで危険だからね こういう人が歩くところ
道路で使うなよとか また決まりまで作ることになりましたし
まあもうただ人間理解してやっているものじゃないんだから
だから今はない あるいは一時的ですね
何でも だからみんなやってる
だからやる アメリカで流行ってる
だからやる それで終わり
そういう話は だから二
三週間で消える その人気も
これも人間はいかに愚かかということを証明する一つの証拠なんです
この早く熱を上げて早くも冷めてしまうというのは
もう純粋な無知な性格なんです
で ということは訳もわからなかったということですよ
乗った瞬間で別に訳もわかって訳分かったわけじゃないんです
だからすぐ冷めるんです
みんなやってないなと分かった
見えた瞬間で もうもう自分も自分はこれこそすごい楽しいと言ったのに
すぐやめますから もうもう明らかにこの無知です
無知な性格の特色です
それで そのキックボードは便利な道具ですよ
ものすごく早く行ける
だからといって大阪まで行けと言ってもね
これが無理ですよ だから早く行く道具なんですけど
弱すぎ そんな風な考えた方がいいんです
だから この言葉で確認することも
もうそれしかない 道具は
これ完璧な道具というわけじゃないんです
他ないんだから使わざるを得ないんです
だから あんまりこの言葉にすごい重大に重大な意味をつけないで
淡々と実況するという方法にしているんですね
それサッマッパジャーノという言葉の意味
それでスウィムッタチット
次の言葉は もう一度繰り返します
怒り 欲 怒り 無知をなくして
瞬間に常に気づいていて
心スウィムッタチット
心を解放している 解脱得ている
心は一切の感情から 煩悩から
いわゆる自我意識から解放しているんです
もう解放っていうのを理解したければ
その方が一番簡単で 自我意識ありますね
私がいるんだぞというね
その気持ちから解放するんです
それが解脱の心なんです
だから解脱を得た人は決して私はこういう風に
これです これが悟りですかと聞かないんです
なんであんた認めてくれないんですか？と
私にはこういう経験 経験あるんではないんですか？とかね
そんな説明したって分からないんだからね
もう勝手にしなさいというしかないんです
本当に悟った人はもう聞かない
誰にも聞く必要ないでしょうね
自我意識消えるんです
自我意識から解放されます
それが解放なんです 自我意識がある限りは解放されてないんです
感情が生まれる 私が花を見ているんだからね
やっぱり美しいか美しくないかという感情が生まれるんです
私がなくなったならば
綺麗でも綺麗でないでも関係なくなっちゃうんです
それで自由なんです 悟りということは
やっぱり自我意識から解放することなんです
それはスウィムッタチット
アヌパーディアノというのは依存しない
とらわれないこと イダというのはここということで
ここっていうのはもうものすごいルーズな意味で
ここ いわゆるこちらのこと
今のこと 自分の今の人生
何でもいいんです 今の生き方
今の人生 今の世界 今生きている世界
何でもここという言葉に入れられるものは何でも入ります
あるいはここでもよろしいし
時間的に言えば今でもよろしいし
不安というのはここの反対で
これからというね まあ英語で言えばここというのはhere
불안というのはafter there
という言葉を使ってもよろしいんですけど
やっぱりhereという言葉は場所と時間も両方意味しますから
英語の場合はね やっぱりいくらか便利なんですね
日本語よりは here
and afterという意味で here
and thereとは言わない
その場合は場所になっちゃうんです
ということは いだっていうのはここで
この世界についてもとらわれない
依存しない 関係ない 自由
不安というのはこれから
これからのことについても
もうとらわれない 関係ない
依存しないという その人
そう 最後の行 そうっていうのは彼
彼が その人がバーガはもう成就しますと
パートナーになるんだと
バーガっていうのはわきまえだから
その人はパートナーですね
サーマンニャッサ ブッダの出家世界のもうパートナーです
ブッダの世界の ブッダの幸福の
それで最終的な意味は
ほんのちょっとだけでもブッダの教えをね
理解する それからその通りに
そのお釈迦様の教えたその教え
そのガイドラインにのっとってちゃんと守ってみる
それで怒りよく無知が消えてしまって
瞬間瞬間に自分に気づくことを慣れてしまって
心が完全に自害心から解放されて
こちらのものについても
これからのものについても
何ものにも依存しない
その究極な幸福を得られます
それがお釈迦様が語っている幸福の世界で
お釈迦様の世界で ブッダの世界
そちらその人はパートナーになっているんです
もう弟子でも誰でもない
もうパートナーです  [背景音楽]それで仏教学者の立場ですね
十九ページ十九番目は仏教学者のことを言ってるんです
随分苦労してるんです
ほんのちょっとのこと言うためには
ものすごい膨大に研究して
大量に資料調べ 資料調べて
それでも怯えながら 不安を感じながらなんとか喋ると
かなりの学者ですけどね
それでもブッダの世界はどれほど安らぎの世界かとまるっきりわからない
あのちっぽけな給料で生きているんです
それは出家した人にも激しく言ってることで
この出家して修行もしないで説法ばっかりしていると
信者さんには可愛がってはもうくれます
まあいつでも教えてくれるとか何とか言ってね
それでもいろいろ何か何かね
食べ物やら衣やら住むお寺やらいろいろ作ってくれたり
それでも調子に乗っちゃって
俺こそ立派な坊主やと
心は汚れたまんまで 貪瞋痴で
まあごく一般の俗世間の人とは何の変わりもない
ということを言いたがっているんですね
このポイントはこちらだけではなくて
まあいろんなところで出てくるポイントなんです
では まあ話はそれぐらいです
何か質問でもあれば  はい
どうぞ  教えに従って理解するっていうこととか
ヴィパッサナーのこと
まあ言葉はね どうでもいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
自分が勉強したブッダの教えなんです
それがたくさんでなくてもいいと
自分が勉強して理解した教えには方法もあるんです
それは何なのかと聞くならば
まあどちらでもあるのはヴィパッサナーしか他の方法ないんだからね
ヴィパッサナーにはなりますけど
最終的には ヴィパッサナーというレッテルでなくてもいいんです
ある一つブッダの言葉を気に入ったと
これをとことん理解してみたと
そうすると方法はそちらにあるんです
あ この方法でしっかりやってみようということになるんですね
そしてその人はそれがヴィパッサナーとは知らないかもしれません
まあ結局はそれがヴィパッサナーになりますけどね
でも 悪いのもいいのもまとめて言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
悪いのはこのヴィパッサナーっていうのは世の中にあるいろいろ瞑想方法の中で一つだよとね
思うところなんですね
まあ昼ご飯って言えばいろいろ食べ物ありますよと
ラーメンもあって そばもあって
うどんもあって おにぎりもあって
ご飯もあってとかね もうパンもありますよとかね
それはもうだいたい誰でも食べるもので
おかゆもあるとかね その中の一つです
だから まあ自分の好みのもので選べばいいんじゃないかっていうことで
たくさん瞑想法があるところで
ヴィパッサナーも一つだというところはね
これが悪いところ ではなんでヴィパッサナーと言いますか？というと
やっぱり世の中たくさん瞑想法あるんだからこそヴィパッサナーと言うんです
だから いいとも悪いとも
そういう言葉を使うしかないんですね
これがヴィパッサナーっていうのは
世の中にあるたくさんの修行方法の中の一つではありません
手当たり次第選択して
じゃあこちらにしますよと
誰かがね ウーロン茶やらオレンジジュースやらお茶やらコーヒーやら紅茶やら
いろんな飲み物をお盆に入れて
どうぞ一つ召し上がって下さいと言ったら
その人はただどちらを選んだってもいいことでしょうね
喉が渇いてるんだったらどちらでもいいんです
自分好みで そういう まあいくつかの中で一つではありませんよ
ヴィパッサナーは本当は
ヴィパッサナーは唯一の方法
それしかないという方法なんです
選択はないんです  はい
そういうことだから このまあ別にヴィパッサナーという言葉にこだわらなくても
あの 各人が自分によく十分納得いったブッダの教え一つ二つだけ理解して
それを真剣に実践してみようと思っちゃうと
その人は悟れます でもそれにはヴィパッサナーという言葉は使ってないかもしれません
だからといってヴィパッサナー以外別なことをやったかというと
そうじゃないんです 例えばこちらで使っている言葉はサン
えーと サンマッパジャーナ
サティという言葉さえもないんです
これはサンパジャーナという言葉から作っているポタンゴなんで
サンマッパジャーナ サンパジャーナというんですね
サンマッパジャーナ だからこれからサン
サンマッパジャーナ実践しますよと言ったっても構いません
ヴィパッサナー実践してますよと言ったっても構いません
はい  他にございませんか
先生  うん  あのー ちょっとこれは素朴な疑問なんですが
あの 昔のそのインドの人が
うん？ 昔のインドの知識人が
うん  あの まあ全部その紙に書かないで頭で覚えて うん
伝承していたって話ありますよね
うん  でも実際にそのインドの文献というのを見ていくと
後からできたものほど
実は自分たちの方が古いんだっていうことを言ったりとか
うん  どんどん話が大げさになったりとかっていうことありますよね
うん  で そういうものは
まああの 多々の人間のその心の働きとして
あの 後から作ったものほど自分が古いって言いたがるってことあると思うんですけど
うん  インドの知識人っていうのは
そういうのをどういうふうに区別して守ってきたんですかね
本当の正しい伝承っていうのをどういうふうに守ってきたんでしょうか
それは私はね まあインドはこんなもんやというふうには
あまりにも大きいんだから
まあ文化的には中国よりもはるかに複雑でしょう
中国は世界一大きい国かもしれませんですけどね
世界一しっかりした歴史を持ってるかもしれませんだけど
複雑さっていうのはね
インドは世界一ですね
多民族で多言語で多文化で
多数教で だから学者らしくというか
知識人らしく語ろうとするならば
もう何も言えないんですね
インドに対しては しかし
私は今日言いたいのは
インド人も気づいてないんですけど
インド文化はすごい爆弾
ショックなショックを受けてるんですよ
前は大人しくて いくらか伝統を大事にしてまとめてあったんです
昔 それがもう集中爆弾落ちちゃって
全部文化がもうバラバラ粉々に壊れたんですよ
今あるのはその壊れた破片文化なんです
この破片文化でみんな色々また体系化作ろうと頑張っている
例えばキリスト教の教えもまんのことなる入って
それでまたインド的この破片文化で
そこをまた何かシステム作ろうと
イスラム教もそれで入って
インドのイスラム人はこの問題作らない人々っていうのは
なんか訳もわからないインド人が
例えばサイババの前のバカがね
イスラムでしょ あいつはイスラムかインド人ヒンドゥー教かどうかもはっきりしないでしょう
そういうことで でも我々知ってる今の現代イスラム人っていうのはまるっきり排他的で
もうもう自分の気持ち聞かなきゃ殺すというふうにはっきり決まってるでしょうに
だからそういうふうな純粋イスラムっていうかね
ことでもないし だから今のヒンドゥー教も
だから純粋っていうことじゃなくて
破片文化なんですね だからそのこの爆弾いつ起きたかっていうことは
また歴史的に考えなくていけないんですよ
で 爆弾最初に起きたのはおそらくイスラム
まあギリシャのあの戦略あって
それからイスラム教が入って
かなり殺しやっちゃったんだからね
アレクサンダーの時代ですか
それからその後ですね
アレクサンダーの時代では
教えとしてはそんなに文化壊れなかったんですね
芸術いろいろ入っただけでね
まあ技術芸術の場合はね
やっぱりギリシャの方がすごい優れていましたから
それは受け取って それを受け取ったのは仏教側なんですね
はっきりはっきりと 仏教は自由で
もう芸術だけも受けてしまったと
まあ楽しい文化だから
仏教はね 仏像やらいろいろ作りたいんだけど
作り方わからない なんかおしゃれ的な建物作りたいんだけど
作り方わからないと もう森の中でも
木の地下でも生きたって平気やってる人々だからね
それでも何も違和感なく
その アーバンカルチャーというんですか
この何でしたっけ 都市文明というのはね
それはまあ受けてしまったんですけど
それで思考が壊れたわけじゃないんですね
逆にギリシャ人もこの教えを逆に受けたんだからね
で それからなんですね
イスラムの攻撃があったのは
それはもう全くもう排他的で野蛮で
もう図書館丸ごと燃やしたでしょ
仏教大学といえば仏教の所ものしかなかったんだからね
ビクロミシラ ナーランタクシラ
ナーランダ ジャガッダラとか
もう世界のスケールで巨大にやっていたんだからね
そういうものはそのまま燃やしてもう潰したんだからね
で 仏像も壊すは 建物も壊すは
もうやりたい放題 それでもうずっとモガルという王様たちにインド支配されたでしょうに
それかなりショックやと思いますね
その厳密に排他的な一神主義っていうのは
もう知ったことも聞いたこともないんだからね
だからバラバラになった可能性ある
それからイギリスの植民地でしょ
これすごい激しい だからすっごい苦しむなんですね
インド人が イギリス人によって
スリランカとは違います
スリランカはもう全部仏教文化だから
もうゴム ゴムみたいな文化だから
向こうはもう殴っても殴ってもゴムだから
また跳ね返ってくるだけで怪我しないんですね
どちらでも しかし スリランカに至っても文化はもうやっぱり壊れたんですよ
バラバラになりましたしね
かなり そこから見ると
スリランカの仏教文化はものすごくもうガラスのように割れて破片になっちゃって
この破片をどうやって今もうどうやって組み立てるかと
みんないろいろ喋ったりして
とにかくそれでもいろいろ考え方出てる
インドの世界でも同じことですね
今行ってみたっても やっぱりみんなむちゃくちゃバラバラですね
まとめてないんです だから自分たちがどこか古いテキストなんかを見て
それで勉強して 自分こそ絶対的な古いっていう風にも言い出しちゃうんですね
ただ 大乗仏教なんかでもやっぱり自分たちの古いとか
言わない 言わない  それはない
うん すごい後ろめたさ
大乗感じてるんだからね
自分たちが古い伝統から脱出したことがよく理解しているんです
その自分たちが感じた後ろめたさなんですね
清浄批判になっているのは
だからテーラワーダ仏教っていうのは全然気にもしないのはそういうわけなんです
それそちらの問題ですよと
だからテーラワーダ仏教では大乗批判っていうのは一片もない
その他の大乗仏教になってくると
もうとにかくブッダを貶して潰して捨てることで精一杯なんですね
これはすごい後ろめたさだからなんです
というのは 権威を作るためには
もうちゃんと伝統を守っているんだぞっていうことを言わなくちゃいけない
でも守ってないことははっきりしている
自分言ってることは前の教えとまるっきり違うとわかっている
それで攻撃しなくちゃいけないんですね
だけど それ自体仏教的じゃない
攻撃型じゃないんだから
仏教は大乗仏教を作るのは構いません
思想の発展とか何とか言ってね
しかし 攻撃型じゃないんです
仏教は 相手を貶すなよとという教えなのに
大乗はもう貶して始めたんですね
インドで だから まあインドで
まあ大乗仏教が現れたのは文化の攻撃ではなくて
このヒンドゥ教の攻撃ですね
結局はね まあヒンドゥ教は政権取っちゃったでしょ
仏教は政権取っていたんだからね
それでみんな守っていたんです
ヒンドゥ教は潰れたわけじゃないんですけど
この 何て言いますか この上の一番上の座からは降ろしちゃったんですね
降ろされてみんな一緒にしてしまったでしょ
だからそちらは元気で
まあ多数派でしょうし
それで仏教は共存するんだから
この式だり儀式 まあ日常生活でやっている迷信などなどは
それは全部ヒンドゥ教任せで仏教はやらないし
で 女の子が何て言いますか
大人になったらどうせ儀式やりますからね
結婚する時の儀式 いろいろ儀式
儀式ばっかりだからね
それは仏教はやらない
でも一般人はそれもやりたいんだよ
自分に子供が生まれたらね
もう七日目でやる儀式はやりたくないって
それはありえないんだからね
それやってあげたいでしょ
そういうことだから ヒンドゥ教はもう仕事はずっとあったんです
ずっとあったんですけど
知識的な インテリ的な的に社会を管理するっていうのは仏教の伝統ですね
これであまり長持ちしなかったんですね
もう王様たち殺したり暗殺したりして
バラモン人たちがまああちこちで政権取って
それからまた戦争することに始めて
それで政権をヒンドゥ教握ったところで
仏教はまあ第一座からどうせ下ろすでしょ
下ろすのはいいんだけど
ぶっ--教には基盤がないんですね
社会の中で インテルの世界でしか生きていられないんですね
文化人の間でしか これでもう
にっちもさっちもいかなくなっちゃうんです
それで生存するために出した態度は
やっぱり今はもう庶民に降ろされたんだから
じゃあ庶民の要求に応えるように
まあして生き延びなくちゃいけないんではないかという
まあ必死んで出てきたものですね
もう王様の助けはないし
すごい商人たちの助けも何もないし
たくさんの坊さんたちもいるし
食べるものもなくなっちゃうでしょう
大学までね 過ごしたり回ったりはどうするかっていうね
それで一般庶民の要求に応えると
一般人に支えてくれるということで
で やっぱり教えを変えないと
で その代わりにいろんなものをちょっとちょっと自分で
まあまあみんなもう頭がいいんだからね
文章書いたり呪文書いたりするのはね
まあそれは当たり前のという
簡単にできます 私にも呪文なんかは簡単に書けますからね
ですから まあそんなのはもうあって
いろいろまあ 日常生活の祈祷やら
あの 何て言いますか こういう祝福やら
そういうものにも参加するし
一般人と付き合ったりするし
そういうことにまあいっぱいこう
大衆に応じるように改良するんですね
改良というか まあ新しく作らなくちゃいけないと
とにかく だから経典を新しく書かなくてはならなくなってしまった
だから大衆仏教と自分たちが言うのはそのわけで言ってるんです
でも 言ってる本人は間違っているんですけど
大乗仏教は大衆仏教なんです
大衆仏教なんですが これはまた勘違いして大乗というんです
大乗じゃないんです 小乗なんです
彼らは 小乗なんですけど
大衆仏教なんですね だから子供が産んだらもうなんとかなんとかそこで祝福式たりをやったり
もう何か病気になったら
それバラモン人のバラモン人がやってあげる祈祷をお坊さんたちがやってあげたりして
それでいろいろお金もらったり
食べ物もらったりする
それが戒律で絶対禁止
食べるもののための仕事を人は絶対いけない
食べるために これほど汚い気持ち悪いことはないんだと
けしからんと だからはっきりと禁止してるんだから
戒律上迷惑でしょ いかなる場合でも金銀宝石っていうのは触ってもいけないんだと
とあるんだから これで儀式によって
その儀式やったら金銀宝石をお布施するというインドの決まりがあるんです
この場合はもう金あげなくちゃと
この場合は銀あげなくちゃとかね
インド文化のヒンドゥー教の決まりがあるんです
一つ例で言うならば このインドもスリランカでも
この女の子が あの 一人前になるんでしょ
何て言いますか あれは
この あれは 生理 あの 最初に生理始めスタートするでしょ
それからはまあ女っていうことで
それがすごい大祭りするんです
で その前はまあ随分自由に遊び回って男たちと喧嘩するわ
もう男殴った日はもう何でもOKなんです
で だから私たちも同じ文化でね
女に殴られるわ蹴られるわ
蹴ったって蹴り返しはできないし
向こうは力はないしね
もう悔しくてたまらんですけどね
で かえって殴ったらね
周りから怒られるし 嫌なんですね
来るのが嫌なの 遊びに来るなよと
しかしこの体が変わるでしょ
もう全部変わるんですね
文化的にも 一緒に遊んではいけないんだと
走ったらいかんぞとかね
男を蹴ったりはするもんじゃないんだぞとかね
それでどんどん女らしくもう控えて
それなりに生活するようになる
そうすると男たちもやっぱり優しくなったんだということでね
また興味を抱くんだけど
それっきり一緒に遊ぶことはしない
まあ一緒にゴロ寝したり
いろんなことやっちゃうでしょ
これ あの日からはもう絶対ダメです
全く別 家ででも部屋が一つしかなければ男たちは外へ出すんです
それからずっと 女の子は中で寝る
兄弟はそこで寝ると 男の兄弟は
それぐらい別れちゃいます
で いわゆる skin ship というか
体を触れたり触ったりすることはもう一切やめるんですね
だからこれは女の子にとっては大変なお祭りで
その時の決まりはそのその日でね
その女の子がつけてあったアクセサリーはね
いくらたとえ高価なものであっても
その清めに来る人にあげなくちゃいけないんです
清め儀式みたいなものをやるんです
披露目儀式ですね 清めというよりもね
自分も二つ見たんだから
自分の家でね やっぱり大騒ぎですね
もう姉の場合は何やってるかはさっぱりわからなかったんですけど
なんかえらい違うなと
なんかすごいマッスリやってることだけは知っていて
で その日にちは決めて
日にちまでは誰にも見せない
兄弟に姉を だからなんであいつは隠れてるんですか？っていう感じぐらいだけでね
でもガサゴソとマッスリ装束で来て
それでいろんな人が来て
それでなんかすごい全く新しい別な服を着て
まあド派手に出てくるんじゃないんですが
着て年上の方々に挨拶をして回っていてね
こちらは全く関係ないんだから
また見ているだけで だからまあ
その時着ていた服やらアクセサリーやら全部もう清めに来た人にあげると
だからスリランカの場合は
もうこれはもうカーストで決まってます
誰がやるかということはね
だからその決まってるカーストの人が来て
全部その清めお披露目儀式やります
インドの場合は これはやっぱりね
それぞれ何か儀式であるでしょ
だからそういう風な このちょっと一つの文化的なことを見ても
この何をくれるかというものも決まってるね
米くれる人 牛やら何か生き物をくれる人とかね
いろいろある そういうことで
この仏教の人々がもう生き延びられませんし
それで生き延びるために一般人の要求に応えようとしたところで
牛はもらうわ 金はもらうわ
男の子女の子もらうわ
まあこれはすべて戒律で明確に禁止している
インドにあった習慣だから
お釈迦様はもう米もらってはいけないと
もう誰かがこの男の子家でいるんですけど
これはあなたのお世話にいろいろ仕事させてくださいとあげますといったら
もらってはいけない この servant ですか
召使いとかね それはもらってはいけない
厳しいって戒律で 全部この文化的なそういうものは全部カットして禁止であって
すごい高級レベルの生き方をもう考えていたんだから
これがぐるっと回っちゃったんですね
だから大乗のという言ってる人々が
やっぱり大乗風に分けなくちゃいけない
だから在家でなければもうどうしても無理でしょうし
だから出家か在家かはっきりしないんですね
出家だといっても金銀宝石は持っているわ
召使いは持っているわとかね
これで困るし では在家といっても
ただの在家だったら誰も祈祷なんかは頼めませんしね
だからいまだに大乗の世界では
自分たちが出家か在家かということははっきりしていない
[咳]ではっきりする場合もあるし
はっきりしない場合もあります
中国とかね 台湾とかはまあはっきりしてますけど
出家ははっきりしてて決まってますけど
やっぱりそれでも財産はいっぱい使ったりはね
まあそこら辺はまあまた違う
そういう風になったもんですね
大乗仏教の本当のところは
それで始めてどんどんどんどん脱線することになってしまった
生き延びるためにやったことなんです
呪文作ったでしょ 密教まで作ったんだから
密教って言った途端 反仏教ですよ
仏教そのもの成り立たない
密教という言葉さえも
はっきり言うと これは密教じゃないんだと
非仏はないんだと 言ってるのに
密教という名前まで作ってしまったし
それも呪文もいろいろ祈祷作ったんだから
だから祈祷文化作ったんですね
それで元の仏教からね
まあこれ自分たちで反省するんだからね
やっぱりいくらなんでも教えは違うんじゃないか
解脱悟りというものもあるんじゃないかといって自分たちが困るんです
自分たちの生き方に矛盾ね
それでまたいろいろいろいろことを考えたりする
例えば悟るところまで呪文と作る
心言作る この心言でここまで悟られる
この心言でここまで この心言でここまでとか
ティベット密教はね それで聞いたら悟りたいと言いますけど
誰もいませんと どうする
だからまあ永久的な矛盾で苦しむなくちゃいけなくなってますけどね
そういうふうな この長い歴史の中でね
ものすごい方面でね 発展したんです
それからヒンドゥー教からもう散々やられちゃうでしょ
とにかくこの論争する能力がないと
インドでは知識人の間では生き延びないんですね
そこで一旦一般人の要求に応えようと思っても
知識人もその中でもいるんだからね
その人々は知識人と喧嘩する仕事は受け取ったんです
ではやってみるぞと いて
それで霊場の中間論やらね
唯識論やらそういうものやら
この実体論やら作っちゃったんですね
それは哲学的に頭でずっと考えて作ったものだから
きちんとシステムにはなっている
でも矛盾は確かにありますけどね
ないはずもないしね ブッダの教えじゃないんだから
それも一緒になっちゃって
崇拝やら仏塔崇拝やら
もう一般人のまた全部入ってしまってね
だからもう大乗仏教といったい何ですかと
どんな学者の本見たって
研究者の研究読んだっても
いまだにわからないということで答えが出てくるんです
実際起きたのはそういう出来事なんです
だから もう それもまあ私が思っているこの爆弾のせいで
その場合の爆弾は中からね
起きたヒンドゥー教の政権
ヒンドゥー教が政権を取ったことなんですね
自分たちのレベルを下がらなかったならば生き延びるんです
それを忘れちゃったんです
金に目が行ったんです
やっぱり金がなきゃ生きていられないんではないか
そこで価値観が変わったんです
金ではないと 金のためには何もやらんぞというところで頑固でいたならば生き延びる
だからテーラワーダ仏教にも保守派にしてしまって貶してるんです
保守派だと貶すんだけど
ずーっと生き延びてる
みんな見えてる自分たちで
昔は一緒にいたんだから
テーラワーダのお坊さんも大乗のお坊さんも同じお寺にいたんだから
初めは お寺はみんなの財産で
別にそちらには誰も喧嘩しなかったんです
だから活動は一緒にやっていたんです
もうこんなこの そういうみんな思ってるほどテーラワーダと小乗仏教
大乗仏教はお互いに貶し合い
憎しみ合ったことはそれはないんです
考え方は違う 修行のやり方も違うんだけど
同じ部屋で2人もいる
そこはもうどんどん消えてしまったんですね
やっぱり一緒に生活できんということで
どんどん別れていっただけでね
どちらでも別れてしまったし
別れても大乗の方がずっともう批判しっぱなしで
まあテーラワーダはそれできないし
別にもう関係ないと もう何を変化したっても
それはそちらのことではないかということで
しかし この世間の言いなりにならない
ならないと生き続けると
生き延びるというお釈迦様の真理をね
テーラワーダの方がちゃんと守っていたんです
だから潰れなかったんです
爆弾はいっぱい落ちたんですけどね
で 例えばスリランカもヒンドゥー教に取られたこと取られたことは何回もあったんです
仏教はすぐ潰できなかったんです
かえって守るんです 面白いことに
こちらはちゃんと仏教的な立場出るんだから憎しみはない
国を戦略的に取ったんだからといって何の恨みも持ってない
そういうことだから では協力してくださいとね
まあそれだったら私たちのことも面倒見てくださいということで話し合いになっちゃって
で 仏教守ってくれるんです
同じことをイギリス人にも言いましたからね
お前ら国が欲しければあげますと
契約書を書きましょうと
契約書を書かせたんだから
そちらの番目番目かの項目はもう仏教を守ることなんです
仏教と仏教のしきたり
儀 祭り その通りに進むことには絶対反対してはいけない
政府は守らなくちゃいけないと約束してしたし
それでイギリス人が約束破ったんだから
あんた方は信頼できんということで一応いろいろ暴動も起こしましたけど
暴動を起こしたって仏教的にイギリスまで行って
王様にまでやって訴える
君 あんたの人々は法律を守ってないんだと
やっぱりそういうことだから
そう簡単に潰すことはできなかったんです
真摯にやりなさいということでね
約束だから だからやっぱり自分の立場をしっかりしちゃうと
もうそんなに簡単に潰れることはない
それ仏教だけの話で 本当は社会の要求にめげなくちゃいけないんだ
他の人々は だって一時的な考え方だからガンコで潰れます
仏教は真理だから潰れません
で そこはもう大乗に変わった人々はそこら辺でちょっと失敗しましたね
やっぱり生きてなきゃダメですと
仏教も生きていればやるものではないかと
生きる食べることは先ですよということになっちゃったんです
同じ問題は紀元世紀でスリランカに起きたんです
ものすごい乾季になって年乾季続けたんです
それからインドからもう戦争かけてきて
王様も逃げちゃったんです
無法状態であっちこっちでタミル人か他の人です
タミル人ではないんですけど
インドにいろいろ国を取ってしまってね
仏教のところじゃない
その上乾季で食べ物はない
国中 その時でお坊さんたちが決めたのは
死んでもこれは守るんだと
何も変えてはいけないんだと
言って若者はみんなインドに送っちゃった
若い坊主たちをね インドに行け
インドに行けと 言って厳密に守ってこいと
国が良くなったら帰ってこいと
で スリランカにいた人々はもう食べ物なくても死にかけても経典だけは守るぞと言ってずっと守っていて
乾季も終わって王様も変わって
シンハラ人の王様になったところで
いきなりさっさとこれは危険だぞと言って書き始めたんです
これ書いておかなきゃダメだと
だから世界で初めて一世記なんですね
経典を本に書いたんです
それすごいショック受けたんだからなんです
ショックとさ 大乗仏教が入ってきて仏教を壊すたし
そこはもう戦って勝ちましたけど
やっぱりかなりダメージを受けたんですね
それもあって こういう歴史的な関係もありましたし
政治的な不安定もありましたし
守る方法はないんだ 相当
というところで本に書くことに決まったんです
そのおかげで今も標点がちゃんとある
だからこの道が脱線しちゃったんですね
やっぱりインドは これはインド人も脱線してる
ヒンドゥー文化さえも
文化的にはもうやっぱり破片状態なんです
だから何言うかと ヨガにしたっても
もう一人一人が自分こそ権威を振るう
ぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃでね
アメリカに行ったら突然変身して別なことになったりとかね
TM やらね ラージニーシュやら全くもう和尚という名前まで変わる
最後にラージニーシュが和尚になってしまうんですね
だからもう破片文化ですよ
言い方 だからもうやっぱり古いと言わないと権威はないんですね
インド文化ではね だからみんな自分こそ古いと言いたがっちゃうんです
いわゆる新という言葉は使ったらカッコ悪いというね
例えば今イラク戦争を起こしたのはこの新保守主義
いわゆる右翼派ですけどね
それで右翼派が現れてきて
それはまたネオコンサバティブという名前でね
で 仏教にはかっこよかったかもしれませんですけど
そういう風にこのネオという言葉を使わないというね
例えばネオブッダもネオヒンドゥーイズム言った途端もうダメっていう意味なんです
そういうわけで みんなもう権威を探す
大乗仏教も必死になって権威を探す
客観的に見るとおかしいんですけどね
自分で新しいものを考え出しちゃって
これが一番古い それ自体でアホなんですけどね
だからお釈迦様みたいに未だかつてなかったんだよと
こんな師匠はと お釈迦様はネオそのものなんですよ
未だかって なんかだから初転法輪というね
そのその経典の日本語で初転法輪なんです
パーリ語になってくると
この初めて現れるって意味なんです
初めての教え 未だかつてなかった教え
未だかつてなかった師匠という
この大胆な発表なんです
だから旧バージョンに全くも関係ない新バージョンなんですね
新説なんです それをブッダがとった態度で
ブッダは初めてブッダからは誰もそういう新説を語った人はインドには現れなかったんです
でも過去仏はお釈迦様の目からは見えるわけですかね
うん 過去仏礼っていうのは
学問的に言えばお釈迦様
それはこの真理だよということを言うために使っている証拠なんですね
例えば地球が丸いということは
恐竜の時代でも地球は丸かったでしょ
その時人間いなかったでしょ
人間いなかったにも関係ないんだそんなのは
だからヴィパッシーブッダであろうが
シッキーブッダであろうが同じですよと
私言ってることっていうのはそういうことなんです
変わらん 別に権威のために言ってるわけじゃないんです
ヴィパッシーブッダも同じこと言ってるんだから
私言ってること正しいですよと言ってるわけじゃないんです
あの 私もちゃんと仏教学を勉強してるわけじゃないんですけど
最近の日本の仏教学者
大学で教えているような仏教学者は
お釈迦様の教えは どんな思想も急に生まれたもんじゃなくてっていうのが前提にあって
あの いろんな文献を過去の何かこういう
インド思想からのつながりでこういう風に言ってるんだよっていうような研究が中心みたいに見えるんですけど
やっぱりそれは どうなんですね
どうなんですか  だからブッダは新説だよと言ってるでしょ
だからブッダは親切だよと言っているにも関わらず
いえ これは親切ではないと今の-- 今更あの学者が言っていることでしょう
だから まあそれはまあまあ給料のためにやっている仕事だからね
それだけのことは別にもう仏教の知識に何か貢献するわけでもないし
その研究のおかげで仏教はすごい発展して広げていくわけでもないしね
なんとかお釈迦様の その
あの 悟った内容を あのー
なんかこう文献的にっていうか
あのー 証拠-- 証拠立てをというか
その こういうことで こういう
あの こういう風に悟ったんだっていうことを一生懸命発見しようとしているような研究
まあそれは無理でしょう
それはもともと否定して始まるんだからね
悟った内容と言っちゃうと
もう人間の能力を全部飛ばしているでしょうに
人間能力を飛ばしているものは
それはただ作り話してるでしょ
もうそれはありえないんですね
全部作り話 後で都合よく変えたものとかね
そういう風にキリスト教の価値観で始まるでしょ
それでまた悟った内容を知りたいんだと
もう学問的じゃないんですよ
学者は だから私は学問が嫌になったのは日本に来たんだから
日本に来なかったらもういまだに学者だと思います
私は計画通りアメリカに行ったならば
もう そんな時間もかかりません
三年で留学終わるし それ見たら
ああ この世界にはもう一日でもいてはならないんだと
アメリカなんか行ったら
まあどうせあんた方の態度的な素性を知ってるし
もう堂々と何のことなく異論反論はできるしね
意見違うんだからといって捨てることはね
ヨーロッパの場合はしませんからね
そういう便利なところもありますしね
こちらは捨てますからね
教授の意見そのものでなきゃ間違いと
新しいものを発見するなよという態度でしょ
だから まあ一日もいてはいけない世界だと
すっごく私の居心地が悪いんですね
いると でも言うことは分かりますけど
向こうは一時間踏ん張って言うことよりは
四十倍ぐらい私は五分以内で言いますけど
言う時は それで向こう側がもうこの話に壊れちゃうしね
これはやっぱり見たくないんですね
一生懸命だからね ちょっと一つの意見を言うためにね
もう何ヶ月か徹夜して研究するでしょ
これを何のことなくこんな感じで言っちゃうとね
これやっぱり失礼でしょうし
最近この佐藤さんたちの関係でね
なんとかって行ったんですけど
やっぱり居心地が悪いというかね
一生懸命調べて調べて言うんですけど
何よこれって  [笑い]だから何って
[笑い]うん はい  ヴィパッサナーがインドでボクラーじゃなくなってしまったのは難しいのですか？テクニックが
インド人にはヴィパッサナーのテクニックが難しいので受け入れにくかったということもあるんでしょうか
まああの それもあります
それはインド人だけじゃなくて
人類に誰にでもなんかすごく受け入れにくいんですよ
簡単単純ですけど なんか怠けが入っちゃうんですね
インド人にとってはあえて難しいんですね
すっごい信仰型でしょ
だから信じることこそ
もうそれいわゆるもう伝統はもう絶対的でしょ
インドでは 伝統 学派 学問というのも絶対的だから
全く新しく全て破っちゃいましょうと
全ての固定概念を壊しちゃいましょうということはもうありえないんですね
一切の概念を潰してみましょうというのはありえないんです
だから難しいんです 今もインドのお坊さんでもいますけど
質がすごく悪いんですよ
ただのお坊さんでなんとか何とかやってるだけで終わっちゃうんです
難しいなと思いますね
それをお釈迦様は知っていたんです
だからお釈迦様がこの
これ誰にできますよということを一生懸命証拠を出してるんですよ
例えばお釈迦様がこの不可触民族の一人五
六人出家させたでしょ
堂々と出家させるんです
一人がこの便所を掃除するというか
町に入って町の便所は全部持って
朝早く全部持って運ぶんですね
外へ その仕事 だからもう日の出前に家に町に入らなくちゃいけない
入って便所は全部持って
もうみんな起きて仕事活動始まる前に町から出て行かなくちゃいけない
不可触民族だから人と顔を合わせてもいけないしね
だからそういう仕事をしたい人をもう狙っていったんです
お釈迦様は朝早く起きて
行ってお釈迦様に顔を合わせたら
お釈迦様 なんであんたはこんな仕事をしてるんですかと
出家したらどうですかと
いきなりお釈迦様が言うんです
ただ 私のような人間扱いもされてない人にはね
出家なんかはできるわけないんだと
受け入れるところがないんだと
言ったら では私がいるんじゃないか
私は受けますよと ただ
この人はもう信じられない話でしょうし
全く信じられない お釈迦様
私がもう出家させてあげますからと言って
連れて行って自分で出家させる
出家させて修行させて阿羅漢になるでしょ
八十大の弟子にまで位を上げてあげるんです
だからそこまでお釈迦様は頑張ったんです
みんなにこれできますよと
カーストも学問も何の関係もないんだ
だから特に女の人々もわざわざと記録して
もう召使いやらいろんなランクのね
お妃からね ただの召使いまで
いろいろ殺陣でいるんだよと
悟った人々はと そこまで学問的に科学的にお釈迦様は証拠を出しているんです
だから できますよということをあれほど言う場合
言うのはインド人にはやっぱり難しかったでしょうね
今 現代インド人と喋ってみると
やっぱりダメっていうことを私も感じますね
やっぱりこういう人々にはまあ新思想っていうのは無理だと
でも頭悪いわけないんですよ
すごい鋭いんです 今も
情報集めることやら調べることやら
もうこれはもうすごい能力がありますね
しかし新説新思考は無理です
どこかで古い概念には依存しちゃう
すいません もう一つ あのサカさん
知恵の開発のことをおっしゃったりと
そういうのがあるんですけど
ダンマパダなんかでもコンパクトにまとめるために
その慈悲と智慧を一緒にこうだよというふうにおっしゃることはやっぱりないんでしょうかね
ここを見てても智慧の方の開発のことをだけ言及されているんですけれども
一緒に智慧と慈悲のことをおっしゃるっていうのはあまりないんですか
昨日はそういう経典一つやりましたけど
なんていう経典なんですか
みてみて  えっと カメラの
はい どうもありがとうございます
あ それといいですか  うん
えっと 二重のところのアヌダンマチャーリーという言葉なんですけど
これはあれですか あの
しながらこういう言葉が入って
ううん  詩として形を作らなきゃいけないから
こういう言葉が入って
まあ入ってたら困るっていうわけじゃないんですけど
下のことを あの で 特別になんか理法に従って
この原理に従ってその実践するっていうことを
その まあ言わなくても
下のことでも十分住んでんじゃないかなっていうふうに私は思ったんですけれども
ただ なんかもう少しいや
そうじゃなくて やっぱり一つ一つ言葉が述べられてるからには
なんかそんな単純なことじゃなくて
なんか意図が お釈迦様の意図があったのかな
あるのかどうかっていうのはどうです
アヌダンマチャーリーと言っただけで言ったことにならないんです
言語学的には アヌダンマチャーリーっていうのはHe follows the principlesというぐらいの意味ですから
いや ですからその言葉いらないでしょっていうふうに思うんです
だからそれ方法だから
ちゃんと言ってる通りにやって
こういうこういう風になりますよと
それは前の偈に合わせてるんですね
あの前の偈では言ってる通りにやらないんだと
この人は言ってる通りにやってるんだと
セットだからね この前の偈とこの偈の明確な差はアヌダンマチャーリーにかかってるんですね
これが access なんです
修築点てつだけね そういう単語なんですね
一応 アヌダンマチャーリーだけでここまで変わるんだよと
前の人はアヌダンマチャーリーではなかったんです
そこが一番問題だった
そうそう 前の人はダンマは知っていたんだけど
アヌダンマチャーリーはなかったと
この人はダンマはたくさん知らないんだけど
アヌダンマチャーリー持ってるんだよと
だからこの二行目を access はこの言葉なんです
よくそのダンマパダで偈が二つセットになってる場合ありますよね
その場合っていうのは
その前の偈で出てきた例えが次の偈でも
よくあるんですけど この場合はそうではないですよね
司会っていうのは出てきませんよね
それは別に  それは注釈書でそれを補っているんです
同じ例え使いますよと
例えば 牛飼いの牛の持ち主の子供が何の苦労もしないでそういった食料食べてるんだと
相続できるんだからね
それにしたらか苦労してる牛飼いには何もないんだと
ヨーグルトちょっとも食べられないんだと
苦労しているわりに 持ち主の子供がもう遊んでいるだけで
もう朝食べる時でも牛乳を飲むわ
ヨーグルト食べるわ 夜も食べたい放題と
こういう風な同じ例えでいきますよというふうにね
ペアになっているとすると
十九の詩は四行なのに
二十の詩は六行ってなんでだろうなって
余計なことなんですけど
考えちゃう  まあ仮にこうやって崩れた方が信頼できるんです
きちんと合わせちゃうと
まあかなり手を加えた可能性もあります
こうやって崩れている場合は
私はより信頼性高いと思うんですね
もっと自然  もっと自然というか
うんうん この宝経でも同じ
崩れているんです 色んなところ
結構崩れているんです
だから古い経典なんです
学者によっては崩れているから嘘っぱちとかって言ったりするけど
それはもう頭が転倒しとるっていうことなんですね
何でも時と場合ですからね
では 少し押してしまいましたが
今日はこれでダンマパダの方は終了したいと思います
この後三十分ほど休憩しまして
五時半からヴィパッサナー瞑想会のほうを始めたいと思いますので
引き続きご参加ください
では 最後に参拝でおわりにしたいと思います
参拝